[Música]
[Aplausos]
es la primera vez que un problema mío es
de todo el mundo
es la primera vez que un miedo mío es
igual al de todo el mundo miedo de
contraer un virus miedo a enfermarme oa
morirme miedo a que un familiar corra
con esa misma suerte miedo a perder el
trabajo o si estás en el sector de la
salud miedo a trabajar niego el encierro
va a vivir solo en casa o quizás miedo a
vivir mal acompañado
miedo a algo llamado pandemia la
pandemia así defino la noticia más
difícil que me ha tocado cubrir de las
cientos de noticias que he reportado
durante mi tiempo en cnn
esta es la que más me impactado porque
la hemos vivido por más de un año porque
le tememos en muchos casos por lo
complejo de la situación ni siquiera le
entendemos pero ante los ojos del mundo
me ha tocado dejar a un lado mis miedos
para transmitir información veraz junto
a por qué no un poco de esperanza y es
que precisamente por estos momentos es
que al menos yo me convertí en
periodista como no apasionarme por lo
que está pasando al menos desde el punto
de vista profesional hablando de mi
profesión mi trabajo por más de diez
años en cnn ha sido explicarle el mundo
a mis televidentes o tal vez explicarles
su mundo en mis televidentes ese mundo
actual el de ahora sin importar lo que
esté pasando pero cómo hacerlo ahora
cómo hacerlo y cómo hacerlo con
seguridad cuándo
lo que hay es incertidumbre cómo se
comunica también la urgencia de una
manera creíble cuando yo tengo tanto
miedo ese ha sido un gran reto pero
también una gran oportunidad además al
periodismo llegó algo que nunca
imaginamos por primera vez en la
historia los noticieros se hacen desde
las casas de sus presentadores y es que
recordemos que la pandemia nos mandó a
todos a casa nos iguala un punto que al
menos que fueses médico o trabajaras en
el sector de primera necesidad estabas o
quizás sigues estando aún en casa como
es mi ejemplo por más de un año y
entonces fue y desde casa desde la
igualdad de nuestros problemas donde el
kobe se convirtió en catalizador de lo
que tiene que cambiar en el periodismo
pero también en catalizador de lo que
tiene que cambiar en el periodista
y quien es periodista la respuesta a
esta pregunta ha cambiado radicalmente
sea por la tecnología o por la
hiperconexión cada vez más visible pero
en qué consiste el buen periodismo esa
respuesta no ha cambiado en lo absoluto
nos cambiaron las preguntas ya no nos
preguntamos quién es periodista ahora
nos preguntamos en qué consiste el buen
periodismo
y seguro haya escuchado que hoy en día
todos somos periodistas no no lo somos
no todos somos periodistas por la
pandemia nos dimos cuenta que no podemos
confiar en cualquier persona que tenga
un blog o muchos seguidores en instagram
o cualquier otra red social y es que
existe una gran diferencia entre el
presentador de televisión y ese bloguero
twittero que con una computadora y
acceso a internet puede auto declararse
periodista e incluso a veces sus
publicaciones se viraliza pero hay una
diferencia entre ellos y nosotros y es
que los protocolos que seguimos los
periodistas para validar una información
una fuente un hecho la imparcialidad que
me exigen en la cadena para la que
trabajo en cnn como hay otras hacen de
nosotros los periodistas una fuente de
información mucho más segura y creíble y
es que la pandemia nos ha recordado a
los periodistas que nuestro trabajo no
peligra por la cantidad de personas que
intentan a veces ser pseudo
profesionales del oficio aunque suene
mal
lo que sí peligra es la calidad de
información por eso la pandemia me hizo
mantenerme firme ante estas convicciones
de informar pero sobre todo de informar
bien y por qué es tan importante ahora
les cuento que en esta época existe una
nueva enfermedad durante la pandemia que
pone en peligro la salud pública esta
enfermedad se llama info demia tanto así
que la organización panamericana de la
salud creó una alerta ante la
propagación viral de la misma la info
dem ya es decir la cantidad excesiva de
información en algunos casos correctas
pero en otros no dificulta que las
personas se encuentren fuentes
confiables y una orientación fidedigna
cuando la necesitan y ojo todos somos
culpables del infoem ya de una u otra
manera y aquí les voy a dar unos
ejemplos las cadenas de la tía abuela
por whatsapp nos falla el mandar cientos
de artículos de cualquier página web en
medio de la noche
tampoco el tweet de ese primo que quiso
estudiar medicina
todos los tenemos en la lista como
olvidar en tiempos de pandemia esa cura
milagrosa que viene en un caldito de
pollo o en mi caso mea culpa a veces
leer o mandar tanta información que no
nos permite enfocarnos en lo que
realmente es importante y si en tiempos
de crisis e hiper información uno es más
susceptible a creer en mentiras o bueno
a creer en facebook si queremos darle un
guiño la palabrita con la que nos han
chalet que ha dado en estos últimos años
les cuento que yo me di cuenta que
durante estos tiempos de crisis como la
pandemia la gente confiaba más en lo que
yo decía que lo que publicaba un
comunicador independiente u ocasional y
empecé a preguntarme porque creo que
esta es la respuesta en las redes
sociales aún no existe una organización
para mesurar lo que se dice y esto
provoca que cualquier persona puede
decir una locura lo que más preocupa es
que en tiempos de kobe una locura puede
costarte la vida
la pandemia me afianzó que para ser un
buen periodista hay que apoyar y citar a
la ciencia abiertamente incluso cuando
sabes que un sector puede juzgarte
necesitamos dejar de creer que la
ciencia es un punto de vista no las
ciencias son hechos hay que hacerle caso
una de las cosas que más me ha costado
el trabajar como periodista son los
contrastes comentarios polarizados
ofensivos en muchas ocasiones de
personas que quieren creer lo que ellos
quieren creer no los hechos por ejemplo
que si uno trabaja para tal compañía
dirá solo es el lado de la historia o
que si estás a favor de la vacunación es
por un interés político por un interés
monetario o etcétera etcétera etcétera
yo sé que ustedes saben a qué
comentarios negativos u ofensivos me
refiero pero aquí viene mi punto los
periodistas no somos sus amigos nuestro
trabajo es cuestionar absolutamente todo
y eso siempre generará enemigos piense
que incluso antes de la pandemia ya me
preguntaba que podíamos hacer para
enfrentar la pérdida de credibilidad y
de relevancia creo que lo hemos logrado
con un enfoque constructivo yo lo
llamaría un periodismo de soluciones y a
qué me refiero con esto al igual que los
hospitales se transformaron para luchar
contra la pandemia los medios y los
periodistas también nos tuvimos que
adaptar en tiempo récord
a una historia que requería una
cobertura constante científica pero
sobre todo global y si hay un efecto
positivo de la pandemia es que nos ha
empujado a que la base de nuestra
información sean los hechos pero también
a recordarnos el siguiente punto
importantísimo para trascender y
conectar
humanizar las historias siempre desde el
lugar de los hechos les cuento que una
de las frases que más he dicho durante
mi carrera es que trabajo en el arte de
contar historias mami me encanta esa
frase y eso fue algo que descubrí a los
21 años en una de mis primeras
coberturas la marcha de las damas de
blanco' aquí en miami florida
ellas son este grupo de disidentes
cubanas que han compartido en el exilio
sus historias personales muy dóciles de
violaciones a los derechos humanos que
sufrieron en su país y yo como buena
joven comunicador en esa época pensaba
que lo más importante de esta cobertura
era quien dijo que cuando y donde aclaró
verse bien en cámara total eso es todo
lo que se necesita no se equivoca estaba
en fin al conocer los horribles relatos
de estas mujeres en cuba' y sentir que
muchas de estas historias me recordaban
a otros relatos que conozco de nuestro
país fue que me di cuenta que mi trabajo
no es sólo contar los hechos encontrar
la verdad si es mi principal objetivo
pero lo que realmente importa es
humanizar la historia que se cuenta
porque así es que a la gente le importa
hace mucho tiempo quedó atrás el
concepto de que el periodista o
reportero es un hombre frío sin
emociones eso es cosa del pasado
creo que la objetividad y la
sensibilidad pueden ir de la mano
tal vez ustedes no han vivido un
desastre natural pero si saben lo que se
siente una pérdida quizás no tenemos a
un familiar que murió a causa del
coronavirus pero sabemos lo que se
siente perder a un ser querido sea cual
sea la circunstancia que no se siente
más en esa mesa que no toque más la
puerta de tu casa
en tiempos de crisis como esta pandemia
debemos entender que si hay que reportar
las cifras pero que es vital humanizar
la historia que se afecta detrás de ella
y le voy a dar un ejemplo perfecto de
cómo lograr lo que yo considero una
clase magistral del periodismo radio el
diario the new yok tramos durante el mes
de mayo de 2020 cuando se acercaba el
pico de 100.000 muertes en eeuu los
editores del new york times' se
preguntaron cómo dar una idea de la
magnitud de la tragedia que vivíamos es
que los números de muertos habían
crecido tanto que se hacían difíciles de
comprender había que humanizar los y así
lo hicieron en la primera plana del
periódico publicaron mil nombres sólo el
1 por ciento de las primeras 100.000
víctimas de kobe 19 en eeuu y junto a
cada nombre una pequeña biografía
albers mit 51 años padre de familia
sueño con ser bombero en manhattan
cristina con de 21 años comenzando su
residencia en el hospital de queens
no había una sola imagen no habían otros
artículos y así continuaron durante
cuatro páginas esa edición se convirtió
en una de las piezas más leídas del
diario the new york times en sus 169
años de historia con hechos con
historias con vidas perdidas que nos
recuerdan a nuestros afectos o quizás a
nosotros mismos
siempre he creído en el periodismo
humanista así lo ha llamado incluso más
que en el periodismo político que el de
entretenimiento o el de economía y ojalá
que ahora al haber tenido todos el mismo
problema vivido lo mismo enfoquemos la
comunicación en un arte de contar una
historia con sentimientos pero siempre
desde el lugar de los hechos y es que
dicen que solo en tiempos difíciles
sabemos de qué estamos hechos que solo
en momentos de crisis ponemos sobre la
mesa nuestras fuerzas debilidades y
aprendizajes y hablando de esa mesa
quisiera terminar mi tesis con una
reflexión personal que se afianzó más
que nunca durante la pandemia no temas
nunca ser la peor de la mesa teme no
tener un asiento en ella y es que a
veces se pierden grandes oportunidades
por creer que uno no podría estar a la
altura del desafío que se presenta y si
aunque eso es algo importante el estar a
la altura de los desafíos
es vital apuntar el nivel donde quisiera
llegar las oportunidades ocurren sólo
una vez en la vida no te quedes en pausa
además nadie se arrepiente de ser
valiente frase que hoy en una conocida
serie de netflix y porque les cuento
esto hoy aquí les confieso algo mi gran
miedo y probablemente debilidad es que
siempre he sido la más joven de la mesa
así me conocen la presentadora más joven
de la historia de cnn y aún lo sigo
siendo a mis 33 años y quizás por ende
muchos ven mi juventud como falta de
experiencia pero les cuento que siempre
tuve muy claro que quería llegar a estar
ahí entre los grandes aunque aún no fue
esa parte de ellos así que busqué un
puesto en esa mesa me traje mi sillita y
me senté para poder conocer aprender y
superarme para un día estar a la altura
porque creo que eso de que el hierro se
afila con hierro es cierto
hoy 10 años después con reconocimientos
que muestran un trabajo bien hecho
después de haber vivido y reportado una
pandemia puedo decir con mucho orgullo
que me siento en esa mesa junto a mis
compañeros de trabajo y hago algo que
hace un tiempo atrás tal vez no tenía la
capacidad de lograr primero que ustedes
confíen en mi palabra en mi oficio
segundo realizarlo con la menor cantidad
de recursos posibles desde casa donde lo
más importante es mi conocimiento
preparación y claro un gran equipo y
tercero tener la capacidad de humanizar
una historia tanto mía como nuestra esta
historia llamada pandemia